I don't think Jay Jones should have been
in that game in the fourth quarter I
thought they should have protected him
and pulled him out their season will be
over without Daniel Jones the Bengals
did the smart decision by pulling Joe
Pearl saying hey we're going to submit
we're going to take our loss and we're
going to move on to next week and get
better that's the best thing you can do
I do not agree with Daniel Jones stand
out there until that last drive that was
wrong I thought it was deceiving that's
your franchise quarterback and he Scout
there with the backup offensive line
still getting sacked and hit I just
didn't understand maybe it was a you
know proven Moment by the Giants I have
no idea a Learning lesson who knows but
I thought Daniel Jones should have got
pulled out